المغرب يواجه اسوا موجه جفاف منذ اربعه
عقود والحكومه تدعم اسعار البذور والاسمده
وزير الفلاحه المغربيه افاد بان الحكومه
تعمل على تعزيز سلاسل للانتاج من خلال دعم
اسعار البذور والاسمده لخفض التكاليف
وتشجيع زراعه النباتات القادره على
التاقلم مع كل الظروف المناخيه التحركات
الحكوميه هذه جاءت بعد ان بلغت اسعار
الخضروات والفواكه في الاسابيع القليله
الماضيه مستويات قياسيه ما في زياده
معدلات التضخم بصوره غير مسبوقه في البلاد
السبب الرئيسي الذي اوصل الزراعه في
المغرب الى هذا الحال هو الماء في ظل هذا
الجفاف الذي عاشه المغرب العام الماضي
ويمتد الى العام الحالي حيث تعمل الحكومه
على استغلال ايه قطره ماء خبراء قالوا ان
المغرب يعاني من شح مائيا شديد في ظل اسوء
جفاف تتعرض له البلاد منذ اربعه عقود
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات